[Music]
you'll get in the holiday spirit I think
we're getting in the holiday spirit now
we are yeah you yeah Hanukkah begins
this Saturday Monica yeah don't be
afraid to classify as you know Hanukkah
is the Jewish holiday that lasts for
eight different spellings have you
noticed that about Hanukkah it's like
what what there's every time I write it
out my spellcheck says incorrect if I
ever have to write it I just I freeze in
fear that I'm gonna do it wrong and then
it's gonna mean something terrible and
I'm German I know you're German and yeah
yeah so it's your turn but you're a
mixture you're German
your journey but you're also slightly
the little Dutch girl you know no I'm
German and Swedish so yeah German and
then the Swedes who just let the Germans
go right through into Norway what did
this turn into the world at war
what happened did this show we're
seconds into it and it's a lecture and
Churchill's stood up to the home right
we should be talking about important
stuff yeah not just babbling like idiots
it's a historic day in the u.s. did you
know that yeah as of today Washington
State has legalized legalized both
marijuana and gay marriage
yeah yeah so today men all over
Washington have two different reasons to
say I love you man you don't know which
one in his so I know could be bother you
hi you're proposing to me or both Grammy
nominations came out today that was
exciting
yes indeed I didn't really care either I
know the Grammy nominations came out
today and South Korean YouTube
sensations I was not nominated yes sir
now will will never know which of his
songs he would have performed
that's right too late that's right
that's right the Grammy nominations came
out and this is interesting both
Michelle Obama and Bill Clinton were
nominated in the category Best spoken
word album now that's good good for them
yeah yeah
- sorry Michelle Michelle was nominated
for the audio version of her book
American groan and Bill Clinton was
nominated for the audio version of Fifty
Shades of Grey
[Applause]
earlier today New Jersey Governor Chris
Christie visited the White House now
President Obama told him I'd invite you
to lunch
but the deficit is already too high
thank you
the Governor of Arizona G about this the
Governor of Arizona this is interesting
punched a reporter who asked her about
global warming she punched yeah punched
him afterwards she apologized said sorry
I'm a little touchy because it's almost
Christmas and it's a hundred and thirty
five degrees outside in Germany Andy huh
yeah
in Germany a man has taken a woman to
court claiming she tried to smother him
with her breasts okay the man is asking
for $20,000 or for the woman to do it
again
[Music]
you don't like the joke you just want to
see that happen the the International
Olympic Committee has stripped India of
its right to participate in the games
yeah in response in response India said
fine just try logging on to your
computers now
[Applause]